bien mesdames messieurs merci d'être
présent ce soir comme prévu
nous allons ce soir vous faire
'l'annonce j'insiste sur ce mot de des
résultats de l'élection à la présidence
du parti des républicains
avant de vous donner les résultats est
que vous n'écoutiez plus que cela je
précise que si je parle d'annoncer parce
que la proclamation absolument
définitive aura lieu après vérification
éventuelle de contestation qui pourrait
nous arriver dans les 24 heures donc la
décision définitive sera rendue mercredi
résultat donc vous savez que les
électeurs inscrits et au nom de 234 1556
nous avons eu 99 1597 votants ce qui
fait donc une participation de 42 46 %
des inscrits par miss et vote en 1054
ont fait le choix de mettre un bulletin
blanc
les suffrages exprimés sont donc au
nombre de 98 1543 et je vais vous donner
maintenant les résultats dans l'ordre du
tirage au sort des trois candidats donc
le premier candidat tirés au sort par la
haute autorité mal de calan qui obtient
9113 voix soit 9,25 % des suffrages
exprimés
le deuxième candidat dans l'ordre du
tirage au sort et monsieur laurent
wauquiez qui obtient 73 1554 voix soit
74 64 % des suffrages exprimés
et enfin la troisième candidate dans
l'ordre du tirage au sort et madame
florence portelli qui a obtenu 15 1876
voix soit 16,11 % des suffrages exprimés
j'en viens un dernier élément chiffré
vous aurez tout cela sur le compte rendu
de cette annonce qui sera en ligne dans
quelques instants
en vous indiquant que la majorité
absolue était à 49 1272 voit donc 50
pour cent plus un plus un demi très
exactement en l'occurrence des suffrages
exprimés
voilà je vous remercie et je vais céder
la place car je crois que il souhaite
maintenant prendre la parole au
secrétaire général du parti
monsieur bernard accoyer